I want Oscar Isaac to blank me in the
blank it's like a mad libs
I want a skies ik to hold me in the
study study hi I'm John boyega I'm Oscar
Isaac and this is first tweets first
tweet oh yeah
Oscar you can go first this is from
Maria sexy ways to spice up the bedroom
where an Oscar Isaac Mass that's what I
told my wife to do all the time ha ha
that's pre-dawn decent I would let John
boyega leave me on read and still text
that man again like nothing ever
happened to be honest and then crying do
you I appreciate that babe I'm busy man
how I feel whatever you never invite me
back in other news Oscar Isaac is still
inexplicably extremely hot to me a giant
lesbian well thank you worldwide
combination laughing yes I appreciate
very much
I want John boyega to explore my guts
and that girl you I'm Christian yeah
like a procedure like medically yeah I
think uh yet cuz like she has guests I
think that by populist writers you okay
good
I don't know that you were trained in
that yeah you go up multiple streams of
fine lines I want Oscar Isaac to
breastfeed me you lactate leather I
don't like date but uh I wish I could
yeah we could try it we could try it
Antonio good John boyega just destroy me
thanks management yeah you could Oscar
Isaac is literally a five-course meal
my ass is sweating so uh duck butter
she's got duck butter it's very sexy
I want John boyega to suffocate me
between he spies that would happen
easily I think we those I was a big leg
Oscar Isaac wearing a beanie while
eating hot cheetos with chopsticks
I've seen that is the reason for every
boner I have I disagree and that's it's
not doing not just it-it's it's a lime
chili cheetos ensure extra spicy wow
that was an awkward at all
thanks guys
[Music]